dieses Thema habe ich auf die
Tagesordnung dieser Sendung gesetzt weil
ich heute morgen gelesen habe Robert
Habeck unser Wirtschaftsminister ist der
Meinung der Staat können nicht jede
gewinnerwachtung erfüllen oder
jeden Gewinnausfall ersetzen ja da hatte
100% Recht ich habe nur bei dieser
Wortmeldung des Wirtschaftsministers das
Gefühl dass der Fachkräftemangel
mittlerweile auch in der Bundesregierung
sitzt denn es geht nicht darum
Gewinnversprechen zu erfüllen durch den
Staat sondern es geht um die Existenz
unzähliger Betriebe in Deutschland wenn
sieben von zehn Betrieben bei einer
Umfrage zu Protokoll geben ihre
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit sei bei weiter
steigenden Energiepreisen akut gefährdet
dann befürchte ich eine schleichende die
Industrialisierung unseres Landes wenn
du ein Haus zerstören willst kannst du
die Abrissbirne nehmen das gibt einen
riesen Knall und dann liegt das Haus in
trümmert du kannst aber auch vom
gleichen Haus Stein für Stein wegnehmen
das ist unspektakulär aber nach einiger
Zeit ist das Ergebnis das gleiche und es
gibt einen untrennbaren Zusammenhang
zwischen der wirtschaftlichen
Leistungsfähigkeit unseres Landes und
unserer sozialen Leistungsfähigkeit und
wenn unsere Betriebe nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig sind wenn sie nicht
mehr die notwendigen Innovationskraft
haben dann werden wir auch den
Sozialstaat nicht weiter festigen und
ausbauen können das ist meine Sorgen
Herr Weißbach mich hat auch schockiert
Herr Habeck hat ja dann auch gesagt dass
wir den Winter überstehen werden wenn
wir auch Glück mit dem Wetter haben
was haben Sie denn bei der Aussage
empfunden von den habe ich keine Politik
aufbauen die Gasspeicher sind zu über 90
Prozent gefüllt allerdings bei einem
normalen Winter
es reicht das für Januar Februar wir
haben aber im März April auch schon
minus Temperaturen gab das ja keine
meteorologische Sensation und es die
Betriebe brauchen Sicherheit Sicherheit
in puncto Entsorgung das gilt natürlich
auch für die Haushalte aber jetzt
prozessguard was also für die
Herstellung von Gütern benutzt werden
muss in der Produktion bekomme ich die
ausreichende Menge oder muss ich meinen
Betrieb schließen ich gehe jetzt nicht
darauf ein ebenso wenn es
Betriebsaufgabe das ist ja eine andere
Baustelle und wie sind denn die Preise
das sind ja zwei verschiedene Baustellen
die gasumlage kommt ja noch on top jetzt
hat ja mittlerweile er Habeck selber die
Befürchtung dass es hier
verfassungsrechtliche Bedenken geben
könnte das klammern wir auch mal aus
aber wenn unsere Betriebe keine
Sicherheit haben dass sie die Energie
bekommen die sie brauchen oder zur
exorbitanten Preisen die sie dann in
ihren Preisen an die Kunden nicht
weitergeben können dann geraten die
Betriebe in Not deswegen muss der Staat
helfen so wie er es bei Corona auch
getan hat Frau würdig sind sie
beunruhigt über die Lage grundsätzlich
oder jetzt darauf bzw grundsätzlich
natürlich man ist ich glaube als
Bürgerin oder als Bürger ist man
natürlich
verunruhigt wenn man das Gefühl hat dass
die Menschen die das Land eigentlich
leiten sollen selbst die ganze Zeit am
stolpern unter dem korrekt also am
Korrektur lesen sind das ist natürlich
nicht das was sich erfahren möchte ich
möchte jemand haben der mir jetzt sagt
wo es langgeht auf der anderen Seite
zeigt es auch wiederum dass es nur
Menschen sind und das ist eine
Ausnahmesituation ist und dass der Stein
jetzt immer mehr ins Rollen kommt aber
macht jetzt nicht so Spaß die Zeitung zu
lesen nein das beunruhigt sehr ja
wer könnte denn derjenige sein die
Leitfigur der ist jetzt hinbekommen dass
wir jetzt ich muss auch sagen ich mache
mir auch große Sorgen vor der die
Industrialisierung wie es unseren Firmen
gehen wird wir machen uns ja alle große
Sorgen und ich darf erinnern als wir vor
einem Jahr den Koalitionsvertrag
aufgesetzt hatten da ahnten wir nicht
dass der 24.02 kommen wird Krieg in der
Ukraine und das sich vor allem die
Rahmenbedingungen die Politik Parameter
dementsprechend so verändern werden wir
haben bewusst beim entlastungspak drei
ja gesagt wir tun was für die bedürftige
Menschen in unserem Land wir tun was für
die Mitte in unserem Land zum Beispiel
Abschaffung der kalten Progression aber
wir tun auch was für den Mittelstand
also für Unternehmen für Betriebe vor
allem für energieintensive Betriebe
kein Unternehmen kann heute sagen kein
Unternehmer kann heute sagen kein
selbstverständiger kann heute sagen wo
er in zwölf Monaten ist darüber muss man
sich im Klaren sein selbst Betriebe wo
die Geschäftsmodelle funktionieren wo
das Unternehmen kerngesund ist durch die
veränderten Rahmenbedingungen
beispielsweise Energiepreise ist im
Grunde genommen alles in der Schieflage
geraten da muss die Politik was tun wir
werden ja gleich noch ich habe ja auch
noch mal ein Thema mitgebracht das hat
auch viel was damit zu tun aber darüber
machen wir uns natürlich große Sorgen es
ist völlig richtig die gasumlage die
gasumlage ist eine Fehlkonstruktion
ja Habeck der Wirtschaftsminister ist
auftragt eine gasumlage ins Leben zu
rufen das hatte er sich vorgenommen
gehabt aber dann haben wir dann haben
wir gemeinsam festgestellt dass das eine
Fehlkonstruktion gibt aber wir hatten
ganz klar den Auftrag gegeben eine
gasumlage ins Leben zu rufen wo a die
Systemrelevanz der Unternehmen
berücksichtigt wird berücksichtigt
werden und B vor allem Unternehmen und
davon profitieren die auch
wirtschaftlich in einer Schieflage sind
er ist derzeit dabei diese Konstruktion
Fehlkonstruktion zu reparieren zu
reparierte Verlängerung ich muss sagen
ich muss sagen aber im Grunde genommen
ist das wirklich das ist die Aufgabe des
Wirtschaftsministers ja das weiß aber
der Wirtschaftsminister ich bin ich bin
zuversichtlich dass der
Wirtschaftsminister in den nächsten
Tagen auch uns ein Modell präsentieren
wird sind sie zuversichtlich ja ich bin
zuversichtlich
die FDP der Druck gemacht dass es kommt
was heißt was heißt Druck gemacht
ich könnte das jetzt ganz billig machen
und sagen das ist der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister aber das ist das
wäre einfach zu billig das in der Form
zu sagen wir sind in einer Koalition und
wir sind als Land in einer wirklich
außerordentlich schwierigen Situationen
nicht nur in Deutschland sondern in ganz
Europa und da sind wir alle gut beraten
nicht parteipolitisch zu denken sondern
erst das Land dann die Partei und das
gilt für alle sowohl aus meiner Sicht
sowohl in der Koalition und das sollte
auch in der Opposition so gelten das
haben sie schön gesagt hätte dieser
Reihen mal sehen ob Herr Kistler das
auch diese Harmonie dieses Wohlbefinden
jetzt weiterführt in gar keiner Weise
wirklich nicht überhaupt nicht also ich
habe mein komplettes Vertrauen verloren
sowohl in Herrn Habig als Ron Herrn
Scholz muss ich leider sagen bis heute
war der Beziehungsstatus von mir und
Robert Habeck es ist kompliziert seit
heute sind wir getrennte Leute das muss
ich leider sagen er hat gesagt ich muss
noch mal sagen es ist eine unterirdische
Aussage er hat gesagt wenn wir Glück
haben und einen guten Winter haben haben
wir eine Chance durch den Winter zu
kommen das heißt es wird offenbar ein
Wetter Schamane jetzt gesucht der also
gut Wetter macht im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium und dann
haben wir eine Chance dass eine
indiskutable Aussage für ein
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ein
Industrienation ich muss mittlerweile
sagen er kann es einfach nicht ich habe
ihm immer verteidigt bis heute habe
gesagt ermüht sich er macht seine
zweifelhaft aber nie so alt
barbescholz kann nur Scholz habe ich
geschrieben kann man nachlesen er kann
mittlerweile weder Krise noch habeg er
kann nur Vertrauen zerstören es wird
ständig mit Hochdruck an irgendwelchen
Dingen gearbeitet die angeblich längst
schon entschieden worden sind herr
Schulz geht vor die Presse und sagt wir
haben im Dezember schon angefangen da
war die CDU noch viel zu doof dass als
Problem zu erkennen wir haben jetzt
september und die Probleme die herr
Scholz im Dezember vergangenen Jahres
schon erkannt haben will sind bis heute
nicht gelöst habe geht vor die Presse
mit Plänen danach merkt man oh
verfassungsrechtlich geht's vielleicht
nicht danach merkt man oh jemand haben
wir vergessen müssen wir nachbessern ich
dachte das nachbesser und das suboptimal
regieren wäre ein Kennzeichen gewesen
der Ära Merkel ist zurück unter dieser
Ampelkoalition des Grauens ich bin
wirklich enttäuscht das schöne ist
herrei hat ja eine Lösung heute
mitgebracht was man jetzt schon mal tun
könnte bei der Energiekrise